i want to ask you about taylor hawkins
passing away
earlier taylor hawkins yes
devastated
because we just played together you know
not long ago and he's an amazing drummer
so kind so generous his laughter his
smile like he walks into the room he's
like
you know he's just i mean
i i'm
i don't even know what to say i didn't
even know what to say or how to feel
because i was kind of still in shock i'm
trying to get through this and then just
go okay wait a minute what's happening
yeah will there be some kind of
remembrance or moment or will there be
anything that the band may do
we're not going to do anything as of
right now i don't know if they're
putting it in the program because i'm
only in the second hour but we'll see
but i hope so because it's it's sad well
the foo fighters were supposed to
perform next week at the grammys that
was just announced so you know i can't
imagine
what they're going to do or what dave
and those other guys are feeling right
now yeah they're they're broken i mean
they're broken it's just really hard
yeah
yeah you need we do want to ask you
about tonight because yes you said it's
an all-star band right but you know
there's going to be some moments
right i have you up no not i mean really
it's star band but it's like i'm just
really i'm chilling it's this
maybe one song but
that's it
we'll see we'll see we're going
i'm serious
it's not my call i'm not i'm chilling
i'm in the band like i'm back and you
know hanging you are never in the band
sheila you are the band don't play with
me